this video is sponsored by squarespace
the best way to make an amazing website
hey guys it's max
right here i have the 24 inch m1 imac
and today we're going to compare it to
the best rated 24
inch windows all-in-one and we're not
only going to compare things such as the
features
the design the performance we're also
going to talk about the displays
the speakers the webcams and some other
surprising
differences and see how well does
windows compete
against the imac now before i get into
the exterior differences i have to talk
about prices
the m1 imacs start at 1300
this one right here is a more expensive
model
and when we get into performance i will
actually talk about both
the performance for the base model and
the higher end one whereas this
hp right here it actually launched at
300 bucks
but you can get it at a discount right
now depending on where you're buying it
now at best buy it is rated 4.9 stars
it is a 2021 model that people are
absolutely
loving now as far as the included
keyboard and mice
with the imac you get apple's magic
keyboard it is a shorter
version ours does have touch id which
you can add on
for i believe it's 50 extra for the base
model
that is very convenient to log in as far
as quality this thing is excellent the
battery life is really good
and the mouse we have apple's magic
mouse a lot of people don't like the
ergonomics i do like how it feels i like
the touch surface for scrolling this is
about 150 dollars worth
of extras based on apple's prices now on
the hp
we do have wireless accessories which is
great some of them actually include
wired
even at these price points and the
keyboard although it's mostly plastic
and the keys feel plasticky
you have a full-size one and the keys
actually feel quite good i probably
wouldn't even swap it i would just
continue using it but the mouse on the
other hand this thing is pure junk
super cheap when you're clicking it it
feels awful the scroll wheel doesn't
feel good
this is something that i would have to
toss and get something better as far as
the computers themselves
we have some differences and some
similarities and i know a lot of people
complained about the chin
on the new imax but look at that we also
have a big fat chin that didn't have to
be there because this thing's actually a
lot thicker than this imac but
it's just the look that they're going
for the iconic imac
chin now this thing actually weighs
about 16 17 pounds it is dramatically
heavier than i think the 9.8 pounds on
the imac
but it's made using a lot more plastic
the outer shells plastic we have cloth
here plastic underneath
the base is plastic as well so it's
interesting how much heavier it is
but one really cool thing because this
is plastic instead of all aluminum
and glass for the imac they actually
included a wireless charger
so as soon as you set your phone down
like this bam it wirelessly charges and
that is
super cool now our imac has a webcam
right where you typically would expect
it whereas the hp actually has one that
pops up and that's cool because you can
get privacy you can
manually close it but it is an extra
step
and this machine does actually have
windows hello so you can automatically
based on your face
log you in but then if it is closed
you actually have to open it up before
it logs you in so it kind of kills that
time saving unless you keep it open all
the time now i'm going to compare the
quality of the webcams as well as the
speakers and displays
soon but let's go ahead and spin these
guys to the backs
and i'll show you guys our other
differences now the first thing that's
interesting is how much taller the imac
is
although it has a smaller chin and it
has the same exact display i know i
complain that it's too low to the table
where this one on the hp is actually
even lower
neither of them can actually be lifted
up you just have tilt right here so both
of them do have tilting built in
our imac has four usb type-c ports two
of which
are thunderbolt and that is for the
higher end model if you get the base one
you only get two thunderbolt
four ports which can be expanded but
that is still a major pain
if you're gonna use this computer with
different peripherals whereas our
hp has a ton of ports
we not only have standard usb
ports we also have one usb type-c we
also have two hdmis one is an output to
an external display
another one is an actual input so
because it's an all-in-one
and a monitor if you want to hook up
your playstation you want to hook up
another computer to it you have the
capability
which you don't with the mac we also
have an
sd card slot and we have ethernet built
in
which is not built into the base model
of the imac the higher end does have a
power adapter
where you can't have ethernet and then
not only do we have those ports
we also have a port on the side here
for another usb which is awesome and as
far as thickness
well we have a massive difference the
imac is insanely thin
whereas the hp not that it's super thick
but when you compare it you know as far
as thickness and weight
there is a pretty massive difference
i think that overall thickness doesn't
really matter that much
but what does matter is the overall
design and even though the hp
doesn't look bad technically looks
pretty good for windows all-in-one
the imac definitely wins we have all
glass here with aluminum
we have the different color options we
have the color matching accessories so
as far as how premium and how good it
looks in your house
i definitely think the imac takes the
win now it's a shame that the hp doesn't
have thunderbolt i really don't know why
because of that when you're transferring
a 16 gig file
it'll take roughly 50 to 55 seconds
instead of just eight seconds with the
mac
if you have a fast ssd but of course the
mac doesn't have an even an sd card
reader
which is kind of ridiculous how little
ports it has
and next i'm really curious about the
speaker quality apple showed off their
crazy speaker design here they said it's
the best
quality in any mac but the hp has this
huge chin right here
that is all set up for speakers so
before we go ahead and compare him side
to side
let me give a shout out to the sponsor
of this video squarespace if you've been
looking to make a website squarespace is
seriously the best way to go
you can make a great looking website
like we did with literally no web making
experience
it doesn't matter if you want a
portfolio a blog e-commerce or anything
else
you just choose from one of the great
templates and customize blocks of text
and images
it's incredibly simple it's affordable
and rs have been running flawlessly for
years now
bringing in tons of traffic thanks to
its built-in seo tools
start your free two-week trial with no
credit card required by going to
squarespace.commaxtech or by using the
custom link down below
and when you're ready to launch you will
save 10 off your first purchase of a
website or domain and now
let's go ahead and compare the speakers
hp is proud
they even have the b and o logo right
here with a little tag on the side
let's see if it can compete is
and there you go guys let me know your
thoughts down in the comment section
below
personally i was blown away by how loud
this speaker system
gets it literally is much much louder
almost twice as loud it seems
and at even 60 percent it's as loud as
the imac
is maxed out now as far as full blast
the quality does go down the base goes
down but it is loud but when you drop it
down to that 60 or 70
percent then the bass is actually even a
little bit
better than the imac and the only thing
it really lacks is vocals but overall i
would have to say
if i can get this sound in an imac as
long as i don't have to have this huge
array of speakers
i absolutely would now apple did a good
job with how thin this is and all the
channels that they made inside
but still i wish the bass was better and
i wish it got louder and now
let's go ahead and compare the webcams
the new m1 imacs
have a 1080p webcam with great new
processing
but surprisingly the hp actually has a
webcam that is 1440p
quality along with two microphones on
the front
as well that are facing you so let's go
ahead and see which one looks better and
which one sounds better
this is the microphone and webcam
quality with the
hp 24 inch all in one
using their 1440p webcam and the dual
front-facing microphones
along with some additional ones and this
is the quality of the m1
24-inch imac using their new 1080p
camera
new microphones which are on the top and
back
and with the signal processing with the
m1 chip go ahead and let me know down
below
which one looked better and which one
sounded better to you and now let's go
ahead and compare the displays both
these are 24 inch displays
but we have a massive amount of
differences
as far as the resolution the hp uses a
1080p
panel compared to 4.5 k
now in reality if we look at the pixels
this one has just over
2 million pixels compared to 11.3
million pixels so over
five times as many pixels and can you
tell while sitting at him
absolutely with imac you cannot see in
each individual pixel
whereas with this display it is not that
sharp you see dots everywhere
text isn't smooth i mean you can
definitely tell the crazier thing is
even on the
larger 27-inch model they still use a
1080p panel so the quality looks even
worse on that one now along with that we
have differences
in contrast and brightness the hp gets
up to 250 nits which is fine in darker
rooms
but the m1 imac gets up to 500 nits of
brightness so it's literally twice as
bright
along with that it has better
reflectivity coatings to battle against
you know reflections in your room so
that makes it even better than twice as
good
and the contrast levels are also deeper
and darker which is great now to add on
to that
the color accuracy is also much better
it actually has dci p3 color
accuracy so if you're somebody's going
to do photo and video editing
you'll definitely be much better off
with the m1 imac
now the display that's packed into this
costs at least seven hundred dollars the
closest thing to is lg's 24 inch
ultrafine
that actually has lower resolution than
this display so the imac packs in a ton
of value as far as screen
compared to something that's roughly
about 200 dollars worth of screen
built into the hp and now let's get into
performance and the first test that i
want to run
is a web browsing test so let's go ahead
and we're going to click start at the
bot with both of them at the same time
all right it looks like our imac got 228
with the m1 chip that is
incredible that even beats out my 15
000 mac pro and yes it is noticeable
when you're doing simple tasks in web
browsing this thing
is speedier than that computer and then
the hp
got a hundred and three
okay well that is lower than i expected
i actually thought it was going to be
about 150
135 40ish so it looks like
the m1 mac is more than twice as fast
for
web browsing and online based
applications
and you will absolutely notice that
difference and now let's see how fast
the ssds are
inside of these machines maybe it
doesn't matter that thunderbolt
isn't included in this machine if the
ssd is slow now i will have to say that
the hp comes
actually with a one terabyte ssd
compared to 256 gigabytes on the m1 imac
you can pay more to get more but it is
spendy whereas this has
a lot more capacity so let's go ahead
and start our test
now bam look at the imac there 2 300 on
the right
and about 2 200 on the read
very very good speeds and how about our
hp
okay looks like 1200 for right in 1854
read so the write speed is about half as
fast or about twice as slow if you want
to say it that way
and actually i guess that is true if you
had a thunderbolt ssd like i did
well it wouldn't do you much good uh
because the ssd
can't keep up when you're transferring
files to it so it's
definitely not horrible it's better than
a spinning hard drive
but it's nowhere near good high quality
ssds at this
at this point and now let's run
geekbench 5 i'm gonna go ahead and hit
the start button the hp does have an i5
processor and it's interesting that it's
a t
processor so i5 isn't the slowest
cheaper ones will have an i3 or
older amd processor i couldn't get an i7
in this model
whereas of course we have the m1 chip
that's in five different macs now we
also have a difference in
ram we have 16 gigs for this higher end
model but the 8 gig one actually scores
the same because of that unified memory
that as has really fast access whereas
our hp
actually has oddly 12 gigs of
ram now they say you can't update it i'm
not sure how you'd access the ram in
here
but 12 i haven't seen a number like that
in a while usually it's either
8 gigs or 16 gigs all right and look at
that guys
we have 1740 single core
7695 multi-core i mean the m1 chip is
amazing as far as the performance for
the money
and then on the hp all right we have
967 single core
that is about 80 slower than the m1 imac
and 4658 multi-core that's about 65
slower multi-core that's a big
difference in performance
even though this is not a four core
laptop processor
this is actually a six core processor in
here
yeah the performance difference is
pretty dang big
but before we get into some real world
tests such as photo and video editing
let's go ahead and test out the graphics
performance this is 3d mark's new
wildlife
extreme gaming test let's go ahead and
hit run
on both of these and see how does this
perform in terms of gaming
it supports all the games but can it
actually
keep up with the m1 chip alright let's
see what we got
we have almost 5 000 points and 29.6
frames per second
just killer graphics performance from
the m1 chip
now of course if you get the base level
that has one less gpu core so you guys
see the score
from the base one right now uh basically
i don't know it's not really worth
upgrading just for that and let's see
what our hp
got why yeah um
786. that is a lot lower than i expected
of course this does have integrated
graphics that are paired with that
desktop class
chip not dedicated graphics but we're
looking at almost 5000 compared to 786
let's scroll down and see the frames per
second yeah we have 4.7 frames per
second compared to 29.6
now there are a few 24-inch all-in ones
that have
mx 350 graphics dedicated ones
those get about 2500 score compared to 5
000
so closer but still half the performance
and about 15 frames per
second so i guess the m1 although you
don't have access to all the windows
games you have some mac games a lot of
ipad games but the graphics performance
is
massive now let's go ahead and shut this
down and see what we get in photo
editing now these are some
edited raw images and even though
lightroom
classic is still being translated
through rosetta it's not a native app
the performance is really quick of
course that's because the m1 chip and
also because of the ultra fast ssd
and if we want to go ahead and punch
into this hot air balloon it is
really nice and snappy pretty much no
delay
let's see what we get with the hp first
off let's flip through some of these
photos
and right there you guys can see we have
about a
three or so second delay depending on
the photo about two seconds there
three seconds there definitely
not as snappy as the m1 takes a lot
longer
let's go ahead and try to punch in here
all right pretty quick to flip to this
one let's try here
all right definitely not bad when we're
punching in but flipping through photos
to load all those effects it definitely
takes a long time
and now let's go ahead and export all 50
of these raw
images to jpeg now the imac is
definitely a head and if we look at our
task manager
the ram isn't actually being completely
used it's close but not maxed out but
the cpu is maxed out
and it's running at about 3.2 gigahertz
that's exactly what the four
performance cores are running with the
m1 imac uh whereas here we have
six of those performance cores so this
should actually be a pretty good
workflow
for this machine and if we look at the
graphics
those are barely being used so we're not
going to be limited by the week
graphics all right our m1 imac is done
let's go ahead and wait for this one all
right the hp
is now done i have our results right
here
and i want to say that the base model
actually is quite a bit slower than this
higher end one partially because it has
worse cooling but also because this one
has more ram
and this machine right here took two
minutes and six seconds
to finish this export that is really
fast now the base model took
four minutes and 20 seconds with the
older version of lightroom before the
latest update might be a little bit
faster now
so i want you guys to go ahead and pause
this video and guess
how long do you think this hp took to
export these photos go ahead and do that
i'll wait a second
all right the hp took four minutes and
four seconds almost as long as the base
imac
so it's actually pretty good performance
overall i was expecting it to be
slower it did great in this photo
editing test but it's still
almost twice as long as this imac right
here that has 16 gigabytes
of ram it is much faster and also much
snappier when you're actually
editing photo and now i want to go ahead
and close this and i want to do
the final test we're going to be doing a
4k editing test because this is going to
push both the cpu and the graphics this
is a standard 4k
project in the beta version of premiere
pro so it's not fully optimized for m1
yet
but as you guys could see even with a
couple luts applied some color effects
it's running perfectly smoothly no
issues
whatsoever let's go ahead and see how
the hp does
let's hit our space bar to play and
okay look at that i don't know what
frame per second we're getting
maybe two three frames per second it is
glitching
like crazy basically you're not gonna
have a really good time video editing
unless you're doing 1080p or proxy files
or no effects
that is a big difference but now let's
go and cue these up
and let's do an export test and now
let's go ahead and hit start and we'll
see how long it takes to export this
five minute project so it's been about a
minute
and it looks like we have uh just over
six minutes
remaining until it's finished premiere
pro is fairly accurate with their export
estimates after you give it about a
minute or so
and i've done this test in the past with
this higher end model that has 16 gigs
of ram and the extra graphics core
it takes roughly seven minutes or so
seven to seven and a half now if you
have the
cheaper base model that one takes about
eight and a half minutes so a little bit
longer let's check out on our hp wow
this thing
says that it's gonna need another 43
minutes to export this project
uh okay yeah i i'm not going to be
waiting that long so basically with the
imac you're looking at
between seven and a half to eight and a
half minutes compared to
about 45 minutes total that is absolute
insanity and keep in mind
premiere pro is not yet all the way
optimized this actually takes two and a
half
minutes with final cut pro if you choose
to use that but if you want the slowest
program
on the m1 mac you're looking at seven
and a half to eight and a half minutes
that is crazy
so what is our verdict how does
the best rated 24 inch 2020
windows all-in-one compare to the new
24-inch m1 imac well i have to say
there's no way i would buy one yes now
that it's on sale
you can buy one for less than m1 imac
it's not the same price compared to at
least the base one
but realistically other than the
speakers being louder and
sounding better at similar volumes uh
and maybe having more
ports i don't know how you would buy
this thing
it's a hard sell for me personally i
would say spend the extra money
get yourself an imac it's going to be
all around a much better computer it's
going to last
a long time you might have to deal with
some dongles maybe you'll spend a little
bit more money but it's going to be well
worth it but you guys let me know your
thoughts down in the comment section
below if you guys click that subscribe
button you can help us reach a million
subscribers by the end of this year that
is our goal we would greatly appreciate
it we have a couple great videos right
over there
this has been max and i will see you in
the next video
[Music]